so Indiana Jones is one of those
franchises that I feel had the perfect
ending after Temple of Doom got some
backlash at the time Steven Spielberg
wanted to send the character out on a
high and that third film was developed
as a direct response to the first two
titled the Last Crusade this would have
Indie riding off into the sunset to get
what's arguably the perfect ending for a
character in Hollywood however just like
the character couldn't leave the past
buried the studios came in and decided
we needed another one
[Music]
Spielberg even went on record and said
he wasn't sure about the whole ending
involving aliens and you can see they
played up the fact that they're
interdimensional beings the Crystal
Skull has a lot of bad things around it
and it definitely felt like the
character went out on his back years
went by the franchise was forgotten
however rumors started to circulate we
were getting one more movie I was
trepidatious but when I first heard it
was attached I started thinking yeah
we're back James Mangold he of course
directed the seminal Logan and he felt
like the perfect guy to tackle a final
Indiana Jones film however a ballooning
300 million dollar budget poor reception
at cans and Wiley mixed reviews have
made this film feel like its Temple of
doomed throughout this video I'm gonna
be going over whether that's the case
and also talking about the movie's plot
and how we leave things off heavy
spoilers ahead and no I know some of you
here one I've seen the film I always
recommend that you check it out before
checking these reviews if you enjoy the
breakdown then please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe of videos like this every day
without the way I'm your host Paul and
let's get into the video sorry
[Music]
well I've been looking for this
all my life
so unlike a lot of movies Indie 5
actually has a four Ox structure to it
with the first part being set in 1944
through the use of the Aging we've got a
young Indie back and this is a major
swashbuckling Adventure like the older
films he's punching Nazis hitting the
Thumbs Up Button getting out of the way
of things by the skin of his teeth and
using disguises in his wits to get
around the bad guys the Third Reich is
on its last legs and the castle
representing history literally Burns
around them as the Germans make a dash
for it
seen things
things I can't explain during this we
meet Indy's Ally in a man named basil
Shaw and also mads Mickelson's bolla
who's based on Werner Von Brown in case
you don't know after the war America
recruited German scientists into their
ranks and this was part of something
known as Operation Paperclip ex-nazis
they never face repercussions for the
war and they were home in the US to help
the country win the Space Race to
cleavolo never loses his actual
allegiances to the Past either and early
on we also get the idea that he's
looking into history now we discover
that the Germans think they've got the
lands of Longines which is apparently
the blade that stabbed Christ this is
revealed to be a fake but the other
prize they've announced is something
known as a dial of Destiny now there's
several artifacts on the train lined
along the side and it's possible that
this might even be the wolverox wall
bridge now in case you don't know what
that is because I've pronounced it
terribly it's basically an urban legend
about the Nazis that involve the train
of gold during the last days of World
War II they apparently fled on one
carrying Treasures but whether that's
what this is I'll leave up to you
India's back though and he manages to
get the dial and vola seems to go out
like Dennis Hopper as he's taken off the
train from here we get a hard cut in
1969 New York with a scene that plays
into the end and an old Indiana Jones
turns out that is some mud died on his
way back to his home planet
sorry turns out that his son died
fighting in Vietnam and the grief of
this has caused him in Marion to go
their separate ways when I heard people
talking about Harrison Ford in this
scene they said he was out of shape and
stuff but I hope I'll look this out of
shape when I hit 80. mathematically the
movie actually deals a lot with time and
trying to recapture that feeling of the
past this happens not only in that
film's outstanding First Act but also
throughout the movie itself the idea of
being able to turn back time with
Technologies what the dial sort of does
too and it definitely feels like a
thematic thing lays shot the film Andy's
apartment gets a strong focus on a clock
and when he retires from work he's also
gifted with a golden one in the film we
also get some flashbacks to the past and
also learn what happened with basil and
his daughter from what we can piece
together basil became obsessed with
Archimedes and finding the other part of
the dial which has been lost to time not
only did he create ways using
mathematics to predict how certain Stars
would move but he also found a way to
detect fishes in time now we've come
good space Volo wants to conquer time
and E2 is just as obsessed with the dial
as basil was now Basil's daughter Helena
is on the hunt too and she tracks in the
down in order to get it back after she
steals it and he's thrown into The Fray
where he faces off against Walla and the
CIA but I'm not a rapper we also see
Solara turn and he drops him at the
airport which allows any to go out on a
Jet Set Adventure this takes him to
Morocco where we get a kind of play on
Casablanca before they meet up with some
divers led by Antonio Banderas finally
this takes them out of the cave of
diagnosis where the dial has supposedly
been hidden out here they discover
Archimedes tomb with him also wearing a
wristwatch and the final piece of the
puzzle to put everything together now a
character of kind of skipped over is
Teddy who's basically Helena's answer to
my boy's Short Round he's a little kid
who's learning to Pilot a plane and he
comes in handy come the final act now
Volare and his forces led by Boyd
Holbrook shoot Indy whilst Helena
manages to get away they take Andy to an
airport come in the airplane and dressed
in full Nazi uniform they fly towards a
Fisher now Archimedes was unaware of
continental drift so we discovered that
his calculations ended up slightly off
bolla believes they're traveling back in
1939 as he thinks if Hitler invades
Poland then they're gonna lose the war
how about what they're actually
traveling back to is the Roman Siege of
Syracuse which as we know has a lot of
roots in history and this happened back
in 214 BC and here we find Archimedes
trying to create the dial Teddy has also
commented a plan to go after the group
and Helena managed to sneak on the main
one just before it took off now the
planar ends fired on by both sides of
the army because they believe that it's
a dragon sent in by the other team nice
little bit of foreshadowing it comes
earlier in the movie and at one point we
see a puppet play showing this playing
out a dragon shown attacking the soldier
puppets as Teddy watches on and I
appreciate this setup earlier in the
movie either way the planes brought down
with Volo dying inside of it whilst
Indian Helena managed to parachute away
Archimedes diseases going on and with
his forces he writes out to meet them
whilst the battle is happening in the
background now in real life Archimedes
actually die during The Siege with a
Roman soldier killing him which could be
referenced here there's a soldier who
seems hellbent on taking in the out but
luckily he's killed before things get to
that point and while comedy's last words
were also do not disturb my circles
which refer to the mathematical drawings
that we see him here working on this is
actually revealed to be the dial in the
movie which we catch the character
working on and I did appreciate that
they at least kept this up now he comes
across Fuller's down plane and also
takes his watch which explains how it
ended up strapped him in his tomb he
also sees the dial itself which makes
him say Eureka and in the past he
creates a thing that will help them in
the future now there's a theory in time
travel but you could say few time travel
known as the bootstrap Paradox which
this entire thing is now playing off of
so how it works is that a scientist one
day gets a knock at the door and he
opens it up to find a book on how to
build a time machine using this they
then build a time machine and travel to
the past which is when they knock on the
door and leave the book there this
allows the person in the past to then
continue this cycle and it's a complete
causal Loop that allows everything to
happen now those that have studied this
principle have said that the book itself
would Decay and every time it was sent
back it would continue to get older thus
eventually it would fall apart and stop
the loop from happening which is why
it's known as being somewhat a paradox
but about here though Archimedes doesn't
take the dial itself and instead he just
looks at it to see what else he needs to
do now India is of course fascinated
with history and thus it's his wish to
just stay in the past Helena argues that
he can't because it's going to affect
everything but he longs to be there
because he's got nothing in the 60s
Helena doesn't want to do this because
she finally cares for her Godfather and
she knows that because he's been shot
he'll have a painful death in the past
mine gives a rising speech but he's then
knocked out by Helena which is probably
going to be something that to divides
the audience for the next 45 years now
what that leads us into is sort of
getting a replay of the first time Jump
where they're seeing his apartment from
the very same angle waking up in bed his
wounds have been banished up and I'm
guessing that he's been cleared of the
murder that he was suspected about the
start Ellen has been watching him but we
see the door open and in comes marrying
along with Teddy Salah shows up but they
all make an excuse and leave leaving
just Marion and Indie in the apartment
together now in a nice little call back
to writers of the Lost Ark we see his
Marion says that it hurts everywhere
though she of course means emotional
pain this is also calling back at that
scene from the first film seeing her
elbow hurts we get a repeat of that
moment and then watches the rest of the
gang guard to get ice cream the film
Clauses out with Indy grabbing his hat
from the outside potentially teasing
that the adventures will carry on now
whether that's the case we don't really
know but Kathleen Kennedy has said there
could be films starring Helena Phoebe
while a bridge is currently working on
Tomb Raider so who knows if they'll go
in that direction and it also of course
depends on the popularity of this film
now you know right you know when someone
says something and you think it's pretty
stupid at the time but then stuff starts
to happen and it seemingly backs it up
well years ago yeah I remember someone
making a joke that Kathleen Kennedy will
Greenlight any movie as long as it's got
a British brunette woman who's part of
the main cast is popped up after Ray and
then generoso and Rogue one and then
after Amelia Clarke showed up in Solo it
started to pick up steam now Phoebe will
abridge look here she fits that mold as
well and potentially I'm not saying it's
true but we might be heading in that
direction with her signed up for Tomb
Raider though it's of course very
similar this and I actually wouldn't put
it past them to try and join these
things together we know they're
different Studios but we have just seen
a big franchise teaming up with GI Joe
so yeah I guess we'll see though I
highly doubt it however that ends the
movie with the hat remaining Indies and
rather than it being a final chapter the
adventure carries on who is this man I'm
a Godfather related
get back
now those are my thoughts on the movie I
did go in with low expectations but I
was expecting myself to love it after
that very first act I'm someone who's
got loads of mates loads I promise they
just work out other channels but I've
got loads of mates who watch these films
early and they tell me what they think
sometimes if they say stuff's bad I'll
still go in with an open mind and sit
there at the start like I don't know
what they're talking about now that's
how I felt here and that first hour was
incredible especially the stuff set in
1944 though the CGI wasn't completely
Flawless it was still about 95 there and
when I've come off just reviewing the
flash you can really see the difference
and recaptures the luck feel and
dynamism of those original movies and
it's an incredible way to open up the
film scoring it off just that out of
giving the movie a 10 out of 10 and when
we cut to New York I felt it maintained
things there too seeing Andy downtrodden
was actually handled really well and it
didn't feel like some other films where
they disrespect the character however
the longer the movie goes on it gets
less and less unlike Indy himself it
feels like it gets worse with age the
Sparks quips and action scenes start to
feel repetitive and I think even just
cutting one of the set pieces would have
helped with the pace a lot of the movie
suffers from them going somewhere then
exploring it the Buddies show up they
escape rinse and repeat you don't learn
much beyond what we already know and the
character development isn't there to
justify spending time doing the same
thing over and over and over again the
final axles are going to be divisive as
well the hard coat that they do with
Helena will probably be something that a
lot of people write you about online as
it feels like they didn't really know
how to get Indie out of there through
using just dialogue I even think just
suggesting that he could go back and fix
things with his wife and see that there
were second chances would have helped
instead of her just doing what she does
so yeah it kind of falls apart there and
it's difficult to argue this movie
justifies its existence you might end up
a bit Harrison bored in the middle and
even come the end it doesn't feel like
the send-off we should have got I
actually feel I could really easily make
another one right after this but with
the massive budget and low predictions
this could be where we leave it with man
gold making Logan I assume this would be
the closing of the book but instead it
just feels like another chapter rather
than a fitting end it's a shame too
because like I said the Last Crusade was
the perfect goodbye but unfortunately
they just can't seem to let go now
ironically mango talked about them
bringing back Wolverine recently and he
said that Hollywood's just gonna squeeze
as much out of the rug as they can being
the guy who directed Indiana Jones I
feel like the calls coming from inside
the house there and that some things
belong in a museum I think this is a
great example of why Hollywood needs to
actually come up with new characters and
IPS instead of constantly going back to
the well with all of the older ones it's
almost at a point where the Aged hero
who's out of Step has become its own
cliche and I hope they start inventing
new characters because in 20 years time
these ones are going to be too old to
milk you also have the fact that the
budget on this is crazy and I think it's
gonna really struggle to make all of its
money back kids don't seem to care about
heroes from the 80s now and to be fair
even 21 year olds now weren't alive in
the last Millennium so you can see why
they just aren't attached to this stuff
and I think if this underperforms it
might change a lot of things in
Hollywood the flash of course is done
badly and I know he's not from the 80s
but there's lots of other movies as well
that might make Studios stop doing these
sorts of films I don't even know how you
get an investor to put money in when
it's no longer a golden ticket and I
think it's going to be necessary to
start scaling this stuff back now saying
that Harrison Ford doesn't miss a beat
and even when he's playing his younger
self he still comes across as authentic
this is an Irishman level where it looks
like an old man stomping someone out and
all the past and while other past stuff
feels like he's actually capable of
knocking people out he really carries
the movie and adds a lot to it that I
didn't even know if he'd be capable of
any more shows my ignorance because the
man still got it and it's crazy to think
this guy is actually older than Ian
McDonald who started as the Emperor in
Star Wars yeah he's older than him so
yeah he's great and as much as Phoebe
while a bridge got up in the leader
for this she acts as one of the better
Sidekicks that the characters had sure
there's not much competition once you
get past Marion but she's there to help
stuff along rather than feeling like
she's a shoving to replace him the set
pieces are great too when they're flying
off but I don't know if all of them were
that necessary now that's sort of my
feelings in the film as a whole and I
think that the set pieces exemplify my
thoughts perfectly admits to like and
they look great but overall you're sat
there thinking how they weren't really
necessary whether Indie returns and oh
we won't know for a while but as an
apparent Final Chapter this just Falls
flat it has its eyes it misses a few
beats but it feels like it's trying to
recapture what made things special
instead of being special on its own I am
kind of going back and forth on her at
the moment and though I didn't hate it
in the end I didn't come out loving it
like how I wanted to it is better than
Crystal skolo and it repairs some of the
things with that but it doesn't do
enough on its own to justify its
creation that third Act is going to be
divisive as well and who knows they may
wheel them out in a couple of years for
one final final horror like final final
Final file is time dot MP4 final Indiana
Jones movie final take dot MP4 I know
it's kind of reek of like they made it
to the end but then realized they could
probably make more and change those
final scenes so things were left hanging
in the end I think this is just a story
that left me a bit deflated and The more
I've thought about it the more
disappointed I am I did see it and I've
slept on it now which lets me clear my
head before this review because I wanted
to make sure things were exactly how I
felt think Hollywood in general does
this thing where we have characters get
a good send off and then the only way
they can bring them back is by tearing
it all down they need to make them
unhappy to make a story they obviously
need to torture them but when you see it
playing out you know you don't feel good
about it that's what happens here too
and to have Indie in the end being
reduced to being a saddled man mumbling
about how he wants to see history it
just made me think ugh this is pretty
sad Phoebe will bridge is going to go
down it's the woman who knocked him out
as well and I don't know they do some
weird things with her character too
she's got a weird subplot with a
gangster ex-fiance has a Wandering gaze
at men and is the character they use to
crap on what's come before I think she's
brilliant in the scenes where she's
walking around figuring out Clues but
the sidekicks definitely feel like they
hold the movie back a bit and what we're
left with is a depressing story of a man
trying to recapture his youth because
the studio can't let go the message in
all these all the sequels seems to be
look fans you need to let go of the past
but Studio mate you need to let it go I
felt kind of bad the more I think about
it but after those early highs it kind
of faded into nothing that's how I feel
about the franchise as a whole you know
it's start off really good but as things
went on it's just got worse and worse
now because of that opening intro which
completely knocked it out of the park
I'm gonna give it a slightly higher Mark
but going off the latter part it did
drop this down so in the end I'm scoring
this a 7 out of 10 if you're a fan of
the franchise but for everyone else it's
probably gonna be a six but maybe lower
obviously let me know your thoughts
Below in the comments and if you want to
support the Channel please click the
join button you'll get early access to
videos it costs 99 cents a month and it
massively helps us out and stay
independent we're not going anywhere and
if you want to buy some merch then
please go over to shopzeroedition.com
and check out all the stuff we've got we
just launched a secret Invasion Pulp
Fiction and spy t-shirt so if you're
watching that show yeah go check it out
now if you want something else to watch
we've got a video on the screen right
now going over one of the things that
we've talked about recently I feel like
we're doing a lot of complaining but
it's coming from a place of love and
yeah hopefully you see over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
taking through the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you next time take care
peace